The USA is obligated by treaty to go to war
for 67 different countries if they were to
find themselves in conflict.
The very first assassination attempt on a
US president was stopped when the then president,
Andrew Jackson, beat his assailant brutally
with a cane before being stopped by a nearby
congressman.
Mongooses were introduced to Hawaii to control
the invasive rat population.
However, rats are nocturnal and mongooses
are diurnal.
Hawaii now has a problem with both.
Spain cheated in the 2000 Summer Paralympics.
10 of the 12 players on their roster “were
encouraged to pretend to be stupid” and
had no mental disability.
A man named Adam Armstrong changed his name
to Adam West by deed poll to match his misprinted
airline ticket as it was cheaper than paying
the airline's admin fee.
A child that was Bart's age when The Simpsons
first premiered, would now be the same age
as Homer.
Higher intelligence is linked with higher
rates of mental illness such as schizophrenia
and bipolar disorder, causing the “mad scientist”
stereotype to have ground in reality.
Surgical masks in Japan are not only used
to prevent sickness but are used for fashion,
warmth, and sometimes avoiding conversations
with strangers.
Englishman Frank Bickerton fought in both
world wars, was drafted into two Antarctic
expeditions, developed a golf course, was
the hero of a novel, killed bears, wrote major
motion pictures, treasure hunted in Costa
Rica and married an earl's granddaughter.
There's a strange phenomenon in the film industry
called “Twin Movies” where eerily similar
movies get released around the same time and
not on purpose.
For example, The Prestige and The Illusionist,
Antz and A Bug's Life, Olympus Has Fallen
and White House Down, Friends With Benefits
and No Strings Attached.
Door knobs made out of brass automatically
disinfect themselves in about 8 hours through
the oligodynamic effect.
The gaping holes that buildings in Hong Kong
usually have are called dragon windows or
dragon holes.
They are put into building so they don't block
dragons' passage from the hills to the sea.
Underneath the striped fur of a tiger is striped
skin, which helps preserves the camouflage
effect.
Mark Spitz, nine time Olympic champion, jokingly
told the Russian swim team coach in 1972 that
his moustache increased his speed in the water,
deflecting water away from his mouth.
The next year, every Russian swimmer was sporting
one.
In 1982, Universal Studios sued Nintendo over
alleged similarities between King Kong and
Donkey Kong.
Not only did Universal lose, but the court
found a King Kong game licensed by Universal
was actually in violation of Nintendo's copyrights.
Franklin D. Roosevelt once accidentally walked
in on a naked Winston Churchill.
When Roosevelt apologised, Churchill replied
“The Prime Minister of Great Britain has
nothing to hide from the President of the
United States”.